our brilliant guest today is a fellow
YouTuber who started her show a year ago
and is now on over a million subscribers
Pearl uh Davis aka just early things
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me oh it's awesome thanks so much
for coming it's great to have you on as
I just picked you up you are you've
absolutely smashed it uh before we get
into all of that uh tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what's
been the journey through life that leads
you to be sitting here talking to us so
um my name's Pearl I'm a YouTuber
um I'm from Chicago I live in London I
do a YouTube show here
that was quick yeah how did you decide
to start it how did you have the idea I
just did you tell everybody what the
show is because a lot of people wouldn't
have seen it oh okay all that stuff I'm
sorry that's fine
um so we talk about a lot of men's
issues so I feel like
most media today is Catered towards
women pandering towards women we don't
do that on my channel
you don't hand it to women no no we're
not about that and pound it to men uh
not panda look it I just say I say
things that are true okay I say things
that that are like basic to me right but
like what
you know you shouldn't get super fat
after you get married just because you
got a ring
that's that's basic women in the 1950s
knew that but today
bully I'm the meanest person ever blah
blah so so yeah that's what I do is we
talk about relationships on my show um
and so we bring in men and women women
to talk about different like
relationship topics and then we go back
and forth yeah and then I'm also I also
work a lot with um
um the court system here I'm doing a
documentary on men getting custody of
their kids interesting yeah but one of
the things you did with your show and I
don't know if you were one of the first
ones but it's definitely a format that's
really skyrocketed I can't open my
Twitter now without you know eight
people sitting around the table having
some discussion often they don't know
what they're talking about but it's a
format of bringing kind of random people
together but partly random very random
very random very random yeah and you
also have famous people and we'll talk
about that as well but that did you come
up with that was something was that
something that you saw other people
doing like no um I would say fresh and
fit in Miami
um we're probably the first ones to do
that so I went on their show and what I
liked about London is it was one of the
most like diverse places I've ever lived
so I just thought it'd be cool to bring
everyone in a room and talk about
something that we all have in common
which is relationships that's very
interesting and so but why do you pick
the subjects that you do why are you
drawn to the subjects that you discuss
because they are controversial they
can't get you into hot water
Etc
um I just I follow what interests me and
I just thought those subjects were
interesting it wasn't a lot of people
think it's like a lot more drawn out
every week I'm just like oh that's an
interesting topic and we go for it
um I would say it's a mix of
relationships sometimes we add in some
conservative stuff but it's like mostly
about relationships and and but and why
why does that interest you both in
particular do you feel the relationships
you're in crisis now or we've done value
relationships or we look at
relationships men aren't allowed to have
standards in society and that's just
like the one thing I noticed like
whenever men
say that they want something in a
relationship like women always shame
them for it and I just thought it was so
interesting how we never like talk about
the men's point of view so when I first
started I I started like introducing my
friends to like certain types of content
so I would be like well have you ever
thought about this this way or ever
thought about that that way and I don't
know that's kind of how it started right
so a men are ashamed for having
standards what do you mean by that let's
just unpick that a little bit okay so
what do we have we have fat shaming if a
guy says I want a girl in shape oh he's
fat shaming oh if a guy says I don't
want the town you know
then he's slut-shaming you know if he
says I don't want to like it's like
anytime a guy demands something out of a
relationship or he's labeled as
controlling and I just got oh my gosh I
got so tired in the past year I get so
tired because I just feel like I would
we would talk about like basic things
and the men would say basic things that
they wanted and like they would just
continue to be shamed for it and it's
just like one of those things once you
see it you can't unsee it so what what
are the basic things and and look a lot
of people who said you use let's put it
fruity language as they would say in the
1950s in England like the town hall oh
yeah no no you should have said you
should have said the city hall the city
hall yeah but so what do you mean by
that
what does that mean because sleeping
okay I met one girl
[Laughter]
she told me this was off camera she
didn't tell me this on camera
girl because we we had a pro-life show
girls had seven abortions wow seven
she's like 28. it's like madness madness
like you can't tell me that's not
Madness right and so we're just in this
world where it's like girls are doing
this crazy crazy stuff
and if anyone has anything to say about
it we're the bad guys it's just like
don't put me in that group like well
that makes a lot of sense because I
think a lot of people including a lot of
women would be like you've had seven
abortions I mean even if you're
pro-choice you'd sort of not be on board
with that most people you would be
surprised you'd be surprised well you
think you think a lot of people are on
board with that maybe not I'm bored but
like legally oh yeah yeah so here it's
free yeah yeah so
um yeah and do you think that these
particular women don't take
responsibility for their actions do you
think it's Society why would it's like
we live in a world where women are
bailed out of every single bad decision
we make if we want to sleep around
there's birth control if birth control
doesn't work there's abortion if if um
the girl does get pregnant and wants to
keep it she can put the dude on child
support and not let him see the kids
like what a guy gets six days a month
maybe if he's lucky
um on top of that if that doesn't go
well you know they can
give it up for adoption it's like women
are always bailed out of every bad
decision we make I heard here they gave
you free housing if you're a single
mother what incentive do we have to make
good decisions if we get free from
the government for making bad decisions
it's a good point but then surely isn't
the system at fault rather than the
individual pill
why
both I mean I think the system's at
fault for like allowing them to do that
but I mean I think your life is your own
fault yeah so if I you can't tell me a
girl had seven abortions that's not her
fault no no no
yeah Francis always likes to blame the
system because he's an article Lefty
things about the system no I mean I
would say it's okay there's good people
and bad people but if you have a system
that allows bad people to do or bad
people to get away with the bad things
that they do
then of course
um the system's at fault too however
nah like your own life is your own fault
so I kind of see both sides when it
comes to that yeah and do you is are
these your politics that inform your
world view do you have a political
outlook on life
um I would say I'm like more
conservative but
like no it's just what I see in front of
me like to be honest you know I deal
that's the sense I get from you you know
ideological you just go that's stupid
that doesn't work etc right that's my
take on that's my sense of you yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I'm sorry I thought you
were gonna say something else there as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible